it needed to be done we would have never
forgiven ourselves if something would
happen elton
and tracy two of you have gone
completely viral
for this really heartfelt story
take me back to the beginning and walk
me through what happened
we pulled into a truck stop and as i was
walking in
there was a gentleman who was
approaching the door i asked him how his
day was and he told me
that he was lost again
i could tell he was pretty far off track
oh i gave you my business card and i
wrote my name and number real big on the
side of it
have a good trip if you have any
questions have any issues call me
so we got on the road and uh about 15
minutes later we got a phone call
i thought maybe he was calling to say
hey this gps thing is great that wasn't
the case
as he's talking when he said that i
helped him along the way and i went to
tracy
never shy away from like little
adventures or anything
and uh so we you know we've never been
to wisconsin together and
we like cheese and you know so we
thought well you know we'll just go to
wisconsin you know
it was just really easy decision was
what needed to be done so we did it
so you guys have this amazing moment you
made it to wisconsin you made sure that
dennis got off safely
and then fast forward you decide
we've got to get this gentleman home so
talk to me about
how you came to that conclusion that our
work here is not done
in my talking with them it became
apparent that there was just particular
circumstances within the family that
wasn't going to allow them
to be able to escort dennis back or put
him on a plane to get him back and get
his truck back to him
and i literally called tracy and
asked her if she was ready to go to
arizona now
you know being of someone his age i have
to imagine he's
he's full of wisdom and some amazing
stories what's been your biggest
takeaway from your newfound friendship
he said to us when we were eating lunch
um
he said you know i see people all the
time on their phones
sharing with their phones that's all
they do they stare in restaurants to
stare at their phones and you know with
their family they stare at their phones
he said to me a phone is to call to make
a call
or receive a call and then you put it
away
who doesn't need to hear that how do you
feel knowing that this story has
really taken the world by storm to say
overwhelmed
is not even a big enough word i just
figured it was like a
glitch in tiktok or something i record
him all the time i take pictures of him
all the time it was i wanted to show
him what i see you know and for him to
be able to look and see like you know
from the outside
you know how amazing that i thought it
was
you know what he decided we were gonna
do there's always good that can be done
we're gonna stay in touch we're going to
make sure dennis is taken care of
are you happy to be home
[Music]
thank god i'm home i'm happy happy
you